in this morning's ion money how low
mortgage rates could help homeowners cut
their costs the average 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage is three point six
five percent that's down almost a full
percentage point from the same time a
year ago almost 63 percent of mortgage
applicants are homeowners looking to
refinance CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with some advice if
you are thinking about refinancing Jill
good morning good morning so if you are
thinking about refinancing what do you
need to know here
well obviously rates are lower and so if
you've got a higher rate than that three
point six five percent you that might
sort of pique your interest but as you
know every single deal when it comes to
a mortgage involves costs and closing
costs on a refi can be two to five
percent of the loan amount I should also
note that when we talk about these great
rates three point six five percent it's
great if you've got great credit and
usually that means in the mid 700s or so
so what you want to do is run the
numbers see how long it will take you to
break-even so if your payment goes down
how many months do you have to be in
that house cuz if you're gonna move it a
couple years may not make sense to
refinance a lot of people are doing kind
of debt triage they got the mortgage
debt they've got the credit card debt
they got the student loan debt can you
refinance the mortgage to pay off other
stuff you can and of course that's
really intriguing because if I have a
twenty two percent
outstanding credit card balance or even
a student loan it's six or seven percent
and I can get a three and three-quarter
percent mortgage sounds great I should
note when the new tax law went into
effect there was a real big change and
that is that you can no longer deduct
interest that is used to pay off other
debt so if two hundred thousand dollars
of your mortgage is your primary
residence but at the another thirty
thousand is credit card in student loans
that thirty thousand you're not supposed
to deduct the mortgage interest so we've
got to be clear about that still it's a
lot cheaper and it may be a better deal
for you to use your mortgage your home
equity to do that so should you think
about refinancing if you have one of
those adjustable mortgage rates I think
this is a great time now yeah and here's
why
last year when rates were higher I got a
lot of people who called my radio show
Podcast and they were freaking out
because their adjustable rate mortgages
ticked up yeah and all of a sudden
they're all scared of those adjusting
yeah me too it looked great when rates
are going down so all those same people
who've had that feeling last year now
could be a chance for you to fix that
loan for the next 30 years and I think
that's important also same thing that
someone has a balloon payment where you
pay a fixed rate for ten years but then
ten years from now you're gonna have to
pay a big amount well maybe your
situation has changed maybe you're not
gonna move maybe you're not gonna have
that influx of money
I think fixed rates are the way to go
and by the way I always share on the
thirty year not the fifteen year I know
what you're thinking you're saying wait
you want to pay it off sooner but thirty
year loan means you've got more
flexibility during the life of the loan
so if you've got young kids and you want
to start putting money away for college
you might say I want a lower mortgage
payment today I can always pay it off
faster if I had to write it what if how
long typically does a refi take Jill and
and what documents you need oh gosh 45
days probably it's still a pain in the
neck
paychecks w2's assets statements loan
statements your whole life your blood
yeah exactly perseverance it hasn't
gotten easier but Jill thank you very
much appreciate it
you